وفي اخبارنا ايضا لها رئيس الاسرائيلي
اسحاق بالامس الى حمايه حقوق جميع افراد
المجتمع بغض النظر عن هويتهم او قيمهم كما
قال بعدما طلب يمنيون يمنيون متطرفون
المرتقبا يشعلوا مناصب في الحكومه
الاسرائيليه المقبله بمراجعه قوانين
مكافحه التمييز مع الان مباشره من القدس
مراسله ليلى عوده ليلى اهلا ومرحبا بك
معنا ليلى اصلاحاتم في النظام القضائي
يسعى لها اعضاء في الحكومه الاسرائيليه
المقبله التي يشكلها رئيس الوزراء المكلف
بنيامين الثانيه هو محور هذه التعديلات
المقترح حاليا صعب على المحكمه
الاسرائيليه
بالفعل هناك انصحها التعبير الماراثون لسن
القوانين والتي يبدو انها حتى هذه اللحظه
يتم السعي وبذل الجهود من قبل الاغلبيه في
الكنيسه الاسرائيلي ونعلم بانها لصالح
اليمين المتشدد الذي شكل هذه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه بعد تبليغ رئيس الاسرائيلي
بذلك ولكن من المتوقع ان تؤدي اليمين
الخميس المقبل اي بعد ايام قليله هذا
الماراثون في سن القوانين يبدو انه حتى
هذا اللحظه ياتي على مقاس هذه الحكومه
ومقاص الاحزاب التي تنتمي اليها على سبيل
المثال بنيامين نتنياه يتصرح اليوم بالقول
بانه
سيسن سيد اليهود من اجل سن قانون
لمحاربه العنصريه والارهاب لا نعلم قانون
في طبيعه الحال العنوان يشير الى ان
المستقيم الجانب الفلسطيني من الفلسطينيين
هناك ايضا قانون المثليين والحله الثانيه
اهو قال بانه لن يسمح في المساس بهذه
الشريحه في المجتمع الاسرائيلي والحديث
لنتاليا هو قال بانه لن يسمح بالتمييز
ضدهم وهذه القضيه كما نعلم تتنافى
والمعتقدات الدينيه للاحزاب التي
وتركز مثلا ياهو في هذه المشكله عليها من
الصهيونيه الدينيه وحزب كبير لذلك القانون
المثليين هذا بشكل
بسبب التفاوت ما بين المعتقد السياسي
وايضا المعتقد الديني هناك ايضا القوانين
المزدحمه ساحه الكنيسه فيها همم قانون بين
كبير
اصبحت تم باسماء الاشخاص الذين تسعى هذه
القوانين الى المحاوله همم تلميع صورتهم
على المجتمع الاسرائيلي نت عن درعي المتهم
بقضايا جنائيه
وتلاحقه قضايا اختلاس وما الى ذلك هناك
قانون درعي الذي يسعى الى فنه من خلال
الكنيسه الاسرائيلي بالقراءات الثلاثه لم
طرحها هذه اللحظه ينص على ان اي
دين الاجرائم جنائيه ولم يحاكم ولم يتلقى
حكما اي تنفيذيه بالسجن بامكانه ان يتولى
منصب الوزير وهذا ايضا القانون كما قلت
يجب ان يفصل على مقاصده
الوزيره
بالمقاعد التي يمتلكها حزب شاس الذي راسه
ايضا
كبير وهو من اكثر خطوره حيث
من المواصلات العامه للشرطه الى الوزير
بالكبير وزير الامن القومي او كما كانت
التعارف وزير الامن الداخلي كل صلاحيات
الشرطه للوزير وهذه اثار كبيره في المنطقه
المعارضه الاسرائيليه في الكنيسه
الاسرائيلي وتم التصويت عليها في القراءه
الاولى في انتظار القراءتين الثانيه
والثالثه تمت تاجيل هذه القضيه بسبب طلب
وتدخل المعارضه بقوه لمدى خطوره هذا
القانون بن كبير علق قائلا بان الوزير هو
الراس الكبرى في هذه القضيه وهو الذي يجب
ان يتولى كل الامور التي تتعلق بالشرطه
بمعنى ان كل القوانين التي لا تفعلها
نتانيا
الى مصر وردتها سوف تتبين لاحقا وهذا ما
بدات تستشعره الاستطاعات الراي
للمشتفع الاسرائيلي الذي تحدث اليوم في
اخر بعد ان هناك توقع لنهايه سيئه لهذه
الحكومه الاسرائيليه والمجتمع الاسرائيليه
شكرا لك ليلى على كل هذه التفاصيل كنت
معنا مباشره من القدس